Shawn Mendes originally said he was just
friends with his met gala date Haley
Baldwin who is now Haley Bieber shot him
it's in a new issue of Rolling Stone
that it was more than that so son Shawn
says I don't even want to put a title on
it he was more of a zone of limbo I
think I'm an idiot to not you know be
can't control your heart wow yeah
questions about Shawn and Haley's
relationship also brought up once again
the massive massive rumor as Shawn
labels it that he is gay Shawn tells the
magazine in the back of my heart I feel
like I need to be seen with someone like
a girl in public to prove to people that
I'm not gay even though in my heart I
know that it's not a bad thing there's
still a piece of me that thinks that and
I hate that side of me so it was in
August that Taylor Swift posted this
video with Shawn's permission of Shawn
backstage at her reputation tour that
fueled rumors even more
yeah this is perfect this is all I
wanted ever
so what was he doing that gesture just
said getting like a glitter on his
eyelashes first or his eyelids so
sunshine says after he gaped him with
permission to post it he woke up in a
cold sweat that night I felt sick I was
like bleep why did I let her post that I
just fed the fire that I'm terrified of
see Adam okay so shot is now happy to
show that side of him as he used to
braid hair and paint his fingernails
with his 15 female cousins growing up
saying maybe I am a little more feminine
but that's the way it is that's why I am
me so sean has just tweeted about this
article he just says of course I have my
own securities and struggles but that's
just one part of me sometimes the
positive side of a story doesn't always
get fully told and I wish it had here I
love what I do and love you guys so much
so I guess the focus of the article is a
little bit too more on these issues and
that's people are pulling this stuff out
of it said he's in a good place but yeah
I don't think anyone's thinking that
Shawn Mendes isn't in a good place but
it's interesting that he has to do this
to remember I guess it's probably almost
two years ago that he did that whole
video or you know he went on camera and
talked his fans talking about how you
know not gay there wouldn't be anything
wrong with that if I was but there's
always a say yeah I wonder why it keeps
on coming up as an issue for him I guess
it's stuff like that the video like that
where he's putting glitter on but I
think but it shouldn't for that though
no it shouldn't at all I'm like I think
too is also a huge supporter of the
LGBTQ community and I was thinking about
that like I don't think we have a lot of
straight male celebrities that are that
vocal nothing there against the
community but I think you don't have
many people that don't like that so
maybe that's part of it that it is so
vocal in support of it sure yeah just I
defer why people keep on going back to
it was shy yeah yeah no I always find it
quite fascinating when a gay rumor comes
out about somebody and it's always
treated like it's the first time it's
ever happened right or he's the first
person I go through he's just a long
line through history of entertainers who
people have thought you know we're gay
and it really doesn't matter one way or
another but people just like to
speculate they always have like to
speculate I don't know I even with him
saying that he felt in a cold sweat
about the makeup things like you got to
not worry about that part of things
because of wearing eye makeup makes you
gay I would have been gay
because I grew up at my peak was 89 when
the more feminine you looked the more
masculine you were right like that's
just the way the world yeah where was
the 80s to like yes and yeah to it's
getting more fluid in that kind of sense
but it's not about being fluid this is
the whole this is the whole thing is
that it you those rumors happen when you
make it fluid as a putting a label on
something where when a guy just wants to
wear makeup it doesn't have to be a
gender thing right it doesn't have to be
a statement right that's where things
start becoming a slippery slope because
then you feel that you have to make a
statement it's not a statement yeah you
just like having your fingernails
painted yes so what I think it was time
for Shawn to say something again is I
think yeah these Brewers have really
been coming up again because people are
making memes and stuff like every
interview it's on on Twitter I know but
I don't exist they're not real people
but no even as fans like say stuff do
you see something like the fans they can
they're totally fine if he was gay yeah
yeah but clearly he's not so yeah that's
how he deals with it right right I'm not
saying he never so I think it's
different like well was talking with
that actors are different because they
can have this kind of mysterious persona
about them like are do you think that
he's had it rough ER than Tom Cruise oh
hell no in terms of addressing it I mean
30 years for Tom Cruise now I know but
something like now like when it comes to
musicians and you had these fan bases
they want you to be open so yeah if
you're hiding something you know they're
fans one I do you open but he doesn't
have guys like you know Stephen Colbert
isn't doing Shawn Mendes gay jokes
that's where his fanbase is right on
social media yeah he's really involved I
mean he started that social media with
binary everyone says yeah Mike says if
you talented what would that word view
what does it matter
Murray says people should focus on more
important things like people not having
a home do the fires in the in the States
sure yeah James does that personally
look at the inside of celebrity along
with the craft if they're great people
yeah what does it matter it grosses it
never ends because they would call
Sean's girlfriend a beard if you had
when it never ends yeah and that sort of
thing with with Haley Baldwin was to
that people weren't sure what that
really ship was sure man